hey dr. Berg here in this short video
we're going to give you a few
hypothyroid diet tips number one the
single worst thing you can do if you
have a hypothyroid problem is going a
low calorie diet why because as you
lower your calories you also lower your
nutrition that starves the metabolism
and you end up just slowing down your
thyroid even more the thyroid does
control the metabolism but adapts to the
environment so if the input is less that
it needs it's going to has to compensate
by slowing and being more conservative
so low calorie diets especially some of
the ones that are like the 500 800
calorie all you're going to do is you're
going to end up with a much much slower
metabolism number 2 pre packaged foods
and you know what I'm talking about the
mainstream big diets out there that are
all the different packaged foods that
you have to buy those have something
called soy protein isolates now what is
soy protein isolates they are a very low
quality protein very cheap protein but
they interfere with the thyroid in the
liver they're not good to put in your
body and when you take those things it
tends to increase the estrogen amount
and anytime you increase estrogen you
shut the thyroid down alright because
I'll help see people all the time come
in and they have a thyroid promises when
it did start after they went in a diet
and they did the pre packaged food so
avoid soy at all costs
number 3 stimulants and that would be
like again these diet pills and vente
mean and things that suppress the
metabolism or stimulate metabolism we
don't want to do that because the
thyroid is exhausted so anything that
stimulates it ends up burning it out
down the road so those are three very
very very very important things to do
now in the next video I want to cover
what I'm going to cover several things
number one what's behind a thyroid
problem and it's usually secondary to
something else and number two why
traditional supplements for the thyroid
never
never work I'll see in the next video